[Música]
está cansado de pensar siempre lo mismo
ideas opiniones y pensamientos que le
mantienen en el mismo sitio y no le
permiten avanzar en su vida no se
preocupe ha llegado télex la solución
definitiva para pensar de nuevo en esas
ideas opiniones y pensamientos
pont en situación son las dos de la
mañana y estás en el sofá con la mantita
sin saber muy bien qué hacer quieres
irte a la cama pero hace tanto frío el
simple hecho de cruzar el pasillo te
parece algo imposible y estás la
película ha terminado la programación de
terminado y todo está en modo
teletiendas lleva 10 minutos viendo un
anuncio de un producto tan
imprescindible y tan importante para tu
vida como la bata manta y sabes que es
lo peor que está pensando en comprar la
oye con esto pero a lo mejor me voy a la
cama antes porque no pasó frío por el
pasillo oye con esto a lo mejor puedes
números frío tanto y con esto pues no
tengo que estar con la mantita de un
sitio para otro te levanta busca la
tarjeta y compras
qué ha pasado cómo se pasa de no querer
levantarte ni para irte a la cama a
levantarte [ __ ] la tarjeta y comprar un
producto y peor aún con ese paso de
querer un producto por encima de todas
las cosas en ese momento a
posteriormente usarlo una vez o ni
sacarlo de la caja porque se había
comprado la teletienda conocéis a
alguien que ha comprado la teletienda
sabéis que esos productos se usan poco o
nada es más para preparar esta charla yo
le pregunté a mi pareja si tenía algún
producto de la teletienda y tenía una
máquina de estas de hacer abdominales y
su madre también tenía otra porque la
teletienda siempre es un dos por uno ni
se acordaban de que lo tenían cuando le
pregunté tuvimos que ir a buscar más y
yo yo nunca jamás he comprado en la
teletienda porque mientras que tú veías
ese anuncio y no sabía muy bien lo que
estaba ocurriendo yo lo sabía
perfectamente y porque yo como buen
vendedor sé cuando están intentando
venderme algo que no necesito y seamos
sinceros las cosas que se venden en la
teletienda no las necesita casi nadie
y se ha detenido que con esta charla vas
a aprender la fórmula que utiliza la
teletienda para vender puede que pienses
que no es una idea que merece la pena
difundir de hecho puede que pienses que
las personas que me han elegido para
estar aquí con otras personas con ideas
que pueden cambiar el mundo y tu vida
pues tampoco tomaban muy lucido el día
que me eligieron pero y si te digo que
gracias a esta fórmula yo estoy hoy aquí
en este escenario y si te digo que
gracias a esta fórmula puedes superar
una entrevista de trabajo ligar o
conseguir que tuvimos se coma la comida
cuando nunca quiere y aún más importante
y si te digo que gracias a esta fórmula
puedes convertirte en un comprador
realmente inteligente un comprador
consciente que compra cuando quiere y
cuando no y cuando lo necesita no
siempre que le ponen un producto por
delante creo que ahora podemos empezar a
entender por qué estoy hoy aquí porque
tampoco sé si alguna vez te has
planteado cuánto tiempo nos pasamos la
vida comprando son 28 mil 184 horas y 53
minutos hasta los 63 años es decir 8
años un 12% de tu vida
va a consistir en comprar esta valla más
porque hoy en día nos pasamos tres horas
y 22 minutos delante del móvil viendo
impactos publicitarios en facebook en
google en instagram y en todas las redes
sociales que están apareciendo eso
produce más de 20 compras por segundo en
internet es decir desde que salida a
este escenario se han producido
aproximadamente 4000 compras en internet
y antes claro tenéis que con la tarjeta
rellena dato hacer cosas más complicadas
ahora hace un clic y lo tienes comprado
pero si hablamos de cuánto tiempo nos
pasamos comprando habrá que hablar de la
otra cara de la moneda que cuánto tiempo
nos pasamos en la vida vendiendo porque
seguro que tampoco lo has pensado pero
cuando fuiste una entrevista de trabajo
cuando saliste a ligar cuando fuiste con
él del banco a negociar algo estamos
vendiendo nos pasamos media vida
vendiendo y aún así lo digamos es pensar
que alguien te está vendiendo algo y
directamente te cierras en banda pero
curiosamente nos encanta comprar eso nos
hace súper felices entonces por qué
ocurre esto somos así de raro o es que
estamos locos
la realidad es que si lo piensas cuando
compras un producto que te gusta y es lo
que haces le recomienda si te compras en
cursos de compra un libro va a haber una
película y te gusta mucho tú sales de
ahí y coge a tu amigo o familiar y elige
te tienes que leer el libro tiene que
estar película y te conviertes en el
mejor comercial del mundo entonces
porque odiamos vender porque pensamos
que vender es engañar
pensamos que incluso cuando tenemos que
vender nosotros nos sentimos hasta
sucios súper curioso porque nos pasamos
media vida vendiendo y nos sentimos
sucio haciéndolo y tampoco lo entiendo
porque realmente vender es ayudar a otra
persona a tomar la mejor decisión y nos
pasamos la mitad de la vida vendiendo a
tiempo justamente eso pero cuando
pensamos en vender pensamos en engañar
pensamos en vendedores de coches en
tipos de personas que venden productos
que a ninguno nos gustan de hecho no
entiendo por qué desde que somos
pequeños enseñan físicas matemáticas
inglés pero nadie nos enseña a vender y
comunicar si lo vamos a necesitar para
superar una entrevista de trabajo
para conocer al hombre o la mujer de tus
sueños y para vender nuestros productos
y servicios en un mundo cada vez más
abocado al autoempleo entonces ahora que
entendemos que nos vamos a pasar media
vida comprando y media vida vendiendo
creo que va siendo hora de entender cómo
funcionan las ventas así que te voy a
explicar cómo funciona esa fórmula de la
teletienda tienes pero en letras tres
letras que cambiaron la forma de vender
y que también cambiaron mi vida y que
también son las culpables de que mucha
gente tenga máquinas de abdominales
inútiles en su trastero pero las tres
letras en la p la a y la s y te voy a
explicar cómo funciona esta fórmula que
es mucho más simple de lo que parece en
primer lugar se te presenta un problema
un problema de tu día a día
posteriormente este problema se agita
hasta el punto de que es un problema que
tienes que solucionar ahora mismo y
cuando está sediento de una solución te
presentan esa solución que es el
producto del servicio que te quieren
vender un problema una agitación que
convierte ese problema en el problema
que está generando todos los males de tu
vida y finalmente una solución que te
elimina todos esos problemas
como no vamos a comprar sé que está
blanco y en botella de hecho yo voy a
hacer lo mismo una venta en directo para
que veáis cómo funciona la fórmula paz
aquí y ahora
entonces yo tengo aquí un contrato con
el que si alguien lo firma aquí mientras
yo esté en el escenario va a poder venir
a entrar apenas toda la subida gratis yo
sólo voy a pagar toda la vida toda la
vida ver ideas que pueden cambiar el
mundo toda la vida todavía viendo todo
este tipo de charlas que perfectamente
podrían cambiarte la vida pero sólo hay
una peculiaridad que sólo se puede
firmar con este lápiz hoy estoy un poco
especial hito así que sólo se va a
firmar con este lápiz pero hay un
problema el lápiz como podéis comprobar
no tiene punta bueno como no tiene punta
y yo me voy a ir aquí en unos 4 minutos
no nos va a dar tiempo y nadie va a
tener la oportunidad de conseguir esas
entradas gratis ahorro de dinero y esa
cantidad de ideas que podéis aprender
durante toda nuestra vida viniendo a
terex pero no os preocupéis porque yo
evidentemente tengo una solución tengo
un sacapuntas
y esto se ha apuntado que te puede
permitir firmar este contrato lo voy a
vender por cien euros cien euros que te
permiten venir a ver en charlas tienes
toda tu vida quien lo quiere que levanta
la mano mueve bueno tengo varios
compradores no se lo voy a vender muy
bien muchas gracias
ya he vendido esto y he hecho un
ejercicio para que veáis cómo funciona
la fórmula paz en directo había un
problema que tú quieres las entradas te
des gratis para toda tu vida pero no
tiene punta hay una agitación que es un
espacio temporal que es el que estoy yo
aquí más decirte qué es lo que te vas a
perder una oportunidad única si no
firmas ahora y finalmente hay una
solución que es un simple sacapuntas
problema agitación solución y como te he
dicho estas fórmulas no sólo ha cambiado
la forma de vender a mí también me
cambió la vida yo en 2014 salí de la
carrera de publicidad y que hice por lo
que hacemos todos enviar curriculum
agencia de publicidad en madrid y en
barcelona envié exactamente 74
currículum recibí un número de
respuestas impresionantes
se de respuesta ahí me di cuenta primero
que no era muy difícil mejorar porque
más que cero no era difícil y en segundo
lugar dije algo diferente se podrá hacer
y lo hice creó una página en la que
presente el problema que tenían las
agencias de publicidad a la hora de
contratar becario posteriormente agite
ese problema contándole las
consecuencias económica y de pérdida de
tiempo de tener becarios que luego no te
sirven para nada y finalmente presenté
la solución el becario perfecto que era
yo ahí volví a enviar ese email y en vez
de enviar mi currículum pues los mandé a
esta página y en vez de recibir cero
respuesta recibir catorce y ay me di
cuenta de cómo funcionaban las ventas
pero me di cuenta también de que yo
valía para algo más que ser un becario
en una agencia de publicidad y eso no es
lo más importante gracias a esta fórmula
yo construí mi propio negocio gracias a
estas fórmulas conozco la mitad de los
amigos que tengo hoy en día gracias a la
fórmula a esta fórmula puedo ver a mis
padres de forma regular porque no vivo
en la otra punta del país y gracias a
esta fórmula conozco a mi pareja es
sorprendente como
tan simple me ha llevado hasta aquí y
como muchas veces las cosas más pequeñas
generan los cambios más grandes como
vemos la venta es una habilidad más en
la vida en master ya que es la habilidad
que debemos desarrollar conscientemente
porque si aprendes a vender si conoces
cómo funciona la venta te puedes
defender cuando alguien venga a venderte
algo que tú no quieres porque ahora que
conocen la fórmula puede decir realmente
quiero esto y eso te va a ahorrar mucho
dinero y más de un disgusto y por otro
lado si sabes vender todo lo que te
propongas echará un pasito más cerca
cada proyecto cada idea cada sueño al
tener esta habilidad de comunicar y
vender podrás estar un poquito más cerca
de completarlo y esto es todo lo que me
enseñó a mí la teletienda y todo lo que
yo quería contar hoy aquí muchas gracias
y a vender y a comprar conscientemente
[Aplausos]